مره جديده تنطلق صفارات الانذار وتستنفر
العاصمه والجيش وينزل سكان كياف الى
الملاجئ باتت غارات المسرات التي تطلقها
روسيا وتفعيل الدفاعات الجويه الاخرانيه
مشهدا مالوفا في سماء العاصمه لا فرق بين
عام جديد وعام مضى انها الحرب التي اقتربت
من طي عامها الاول
غارات روسيه مره اخرى ضربت البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه في كييف ومحيطها تسببت معها بانقاع
واسع للتيار الكهربائي عن العاصمه وعده
مناطقون يمكنكم الشعور بهذا وهم محقون في
الخوف لانه سيزمون الطائرات بدون طيار
والصواريخ وكل شيء اخر لن يساعدهم لاننا
نقف متحدين هم فقط يوحدهم الخوف ولن يسلب
استقلالنا
الهجمات الروسيه طالت كذلك مناطق اخرى كاد
نبرو وبترو بيسكو وزباروجيا حيث اسقطت
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه 9 سيارات روسيه
ايرانيه الصنع لكن رغم الخسائر الفادحه
التي لحقت بالبنيه التحتيه في اوكرانيا
الا ان وحدات الجيش تؤكد ان نسب النجاح في
التصدي للهجمات الروسيه ارتفعت الى نحو
80%
انس نماسي العربيه